mais que veulent les scientologie sts
finalement la puissance et le contrôle
total de la conscience des hommes
[Musique]
nous sommes en angleterre dans un manoir
du sussex qui appartint au maharaja de
jaipur
c'est là que l'église international de
scientologie a installé son quartier
général
le fondateur et grand maître un ancien
écrivain de science-fiction ron hubbard
d' népal interdit de séjour en
angleterre depuis quatre ans il navigue
en méditerranée sur son yacht de 3300
tonnes battant pavillon panaméen
si je voulais étudier la scientologie
que devrais-je faire d'abord on
suggérait d'abord devenir un livre de
base par exemple la dianétique le
premier livre concernant l'esprit qui
était écrit par ron bard et là nous
abordons la philosophie religieuse
là intervient la scientologie
ai-je besoin d'argent pour apprendre la
scientologie
vous avez toujours besoin d'argent ou de
bonne volonté pour contribuer à quelque
chose ce qui est nécessaire et c'est là
un concept traditionnel en philosophie
il est toujours indispensable de faire
une contribution
si vous avez de l'argent vous devez
payer si vous n'en avez pas vous devez
donner votre travail
la scientologie souvenez vous on n'a que
20 ans d'existence
zaho et la plus grande partie de notre
argent sert à son extension chacun jour
un nouveau centre de scientologie et
créer quelque part dans le monde cela
veut dire que des immeubles doivent être
édifiées des livres doivent être
traduits un encadrement on doit être
payé et tout cela demande beaucoup
d'argent et scientologues ont été
poursuivis condamnés ici et là mais ils
sont aujourd'hui plusieurs millions ils
sont présents dans 22 pays d'ici de ce
manoir l'état major est en contact
permanent avec tous les autres centres
vous pouvez à tout moment communiquer
avec ron à barnes il vous répondra
directement
et le plus grand homme de cette planète
pour moi c'est ça ne fait aucun doute il
est plus important qu'il met sa lucidité
et ses connaissances au service de sa
recherche
plutôt que de vouloir devenir célèbre il
n'a pas besoin de devenir célèbre car
ils vous sentez-vous particulièrement
puissante dans votre rôle de commandant
en chef de l'église
non la puissance
la seule vraie puissance consiste à
servir autrui
mon seul but est de permettre à la
scientologie de se propager et de
s'étendre
vous êtes donc libre de vouloir ou non
entrer dans l'église vous voyez la
volonté de puissance personnelle n'entre
pas en ligne de compte
chaque jour pendant 10 heures
la voix enregistrée de barde enseigne
inlassablement sa vérité les adeptes
doivent se confesser confier leurs
pensées les plus intimes à ce détecteur
de mensonges électronique barde emprunte
aussi bien aux églises qu'à la
psychanalyse ou aux techniques
policières apprendre à se dominer mais
aussi à dominer les autres
c'est un des exercices de base
sur ces poupées les adeptes doivent se
jeter leurs traumatismes leurs pulsions
leur angoisse pour tenter de s'en
libérer
qu'est ce que tu as trouvé tout ce que
je veux cette joie de vivre puissance
que j'aime les personnes s'étaient j'ai
trouvé une philosophie pratique qui me
donne et qui donnait mes amis des
changements désirable dans ma vie
faut-il que le monde devienne
scientologues pour pouvoir être heureux
témoin je suis heureuse maintenant
justement maintenant mais ça va venir un
jour il ya quand même temps que dans la
scientologie vita depuis 1964 pourquoi
est-ce que vous êtes entre eux piqué au
vif je voulais savoir sur les dès l'an
prochain
moi même et ma famille et comment est ce
que vous avez connaissance de
l'existence bien j'ai quitté la france
en 63 j'y suis arrivé en australie est
un ami et notre passion de l'orgue
habitaient dans la maison objet terre il
m'a dit qu'il était sûr de leur demander
qu'est ce que c'est mélanie un livre
j'ai lu est ce que j'ai lu j'ai émis
donc je suis scientologues
vous avez vous-même de vie ou une vie
antérieure
ok je vous donne se tenait non c'est un
peu je crois que j'étais en grèce c'est
très bien que la grèce je suis rappelé
de l'israël aussi ce soir deux exemples
où dame
vous allez avoir une vie ultérieure
c'est ce que vous croyez être immortel
tu crois pas je sais nous sommes fiers
de remettre aujourd'hui un diplôme du
cours spécial du collège de scientologie
ainsi toutes les semaines des adeptes
sont déclarés opérationnels ils peuvent
regagner le monde extérieur pour y
servir la cause scientologie
[Applaudissements]
d'autres signant un contrat dit il
s'engage dans le système d'encadrement
il embarque sur une des quatre unités de
la cie orgue
l'organisation de la mer bienvenue à
bord de l'athena pour le service
religieux
voici le credo de l'église en 1965 j'ai
réalisé que j'avais un besoin de
changement dans ma vie je me suis alors
intéressé à toutes sortes de religions
et de philosophie et je n'en ai trouvé
aucune qui m'apporte ce que je désirais
une nouvelle connaissance puis j'ai lu
un livre de vendre et barbe
j'ai compris je suis devenu
scientologues est plus intéressant
d'être le commandant de bâtiments de la
scientologie que d'un autre bien sûr car
normalement vous travaillez pour gagner
de l'argent mais en faisant ce que je
fais j'aide les jeunes gens dans notre
église accroître leurs capacités leur
pouvoir sur la vie alors apprendre à
devenir les membres d'une équipe être
des responsables cette église a aussi
son excommunication pour les
scientologues cet homme est un criminel
et un ennemi pendant combien de temps
avez vous été scientologues ce sens
j'étais si dans la scientologie pendant
14 ans et pourquoi avez vous quitté
parce que j'en ai été exclu je veux
offenser leur code moral je ne croyais
plus en eux pouvez-vous être plus précis
vous n'étiez pas libre aucun
scientologues n'est libre de sa pensée
il doit absolument suivre à la lettre
comme un esclave les paroles de rabat
s'il ne le fait pas s'ils cherchent à
penser de lui même il est expulsé exclu
ils sont tout-à-fait fasciste en fait
ils veulent manipuler les consciences de
gens les scientologues sont en france
depuis trois ans
[Musique]